un point ce matin sur
l'état des connaissances sur la variole
simienne l'évolution de la situation
épidémique mais surtout aussi sur les
mesures prises ou envisagées par les
autorités sanitaires en particulier en
termes de vaccination
et je les remercie de leur présence et
nous allons tendre ce matin le
professeur xavier lescure caire vexiau
log à l'hôpital bichat
monsieur bruno coignard directeur des
maladies infectieuses
et monsieur françois beck directeur de
la prévention et de la promotion de
santé publique france et le docteur
clément lazarus adjoint à la
sous-directrice veille et sécurité
sanitaire qui représente la direction
générale de la santé j'indique que cette
audition est l'objet d'une captation
vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat je salue nos collègues et
assistent à cette réunion par visio
conférence
et pour commencer je vais passer la
parole au professeur lescure
madame de roche mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
je sais parler près du micro tuer je
vais vous dressez un résumé de la
situation clinique je pense que c'est ce
qui me demandait aujourd'hui je pourrais
avoir des remarques aussi sur
des les les évaluations ou les
évolutions en termes épidémiologique
mais spf est là et sur les contraintes
opérationnelles en termes de prise en
charge et traitement pour vous donner un
état des lieux du terrain
pour vous résumer rapidement la
situation clinique on a affaire à une
variole simienne qui jusqu'àlors n'avait
pas beaucoup dépassé les zones d'endémie
qui se présentait
pardon dans le cadre de zoonoses
essentiellement avec une transmission
interhumaine peu fréquente
qui touche est essentiellement les
chasseurs ou les enfants qui étaient en
contact avec les animaux porteurs du
virus essentiellement les rongeurs et
les singes et qui
sur cette infection virale à virus à
gros virus à adn enveloppé qui est assez
résistant en milieu l'inerte provoqué
sur la phase
virer milk de d'invasion systémique des
signes généraux de type fièvre syndrome
pseudo grippal est ensuite envoyé
l'émergence de lésions cutanées ou
cutanées aux muqueuses
d'évolution mono synchrone c'est à dire
en une seule phase
de la maladie qui touche essentiellement
la peau avec des lésions qui durèrent
qui dure excusez-moi environ trois
semaines
avant de cicatriser
une fois que les croûtes tombe et
pouvant laisser des séquelles
cicatricielles is esthétique
le pronostic de cette maladie connue en
zone d'endémie est variable en fonction
des régions et des sous types viraux
sur les données qu'on a et on pense
qu'elles sont pas forcément très
précises en termes de dénominateurs par
rapport au nombre de patients touchés
par rapport au contexte de la zone
d'endémie il est
on considère que la mortalité est de
environ 30% pour le sous type viral
évoluant en zone d'afrique centrale et
de 10% en afrique de l'ouest aujourd'hui
il veut sous type viral qui s'est
disséminé en dehors de la zone d'endémie
et celui d'afrique de l'ouest qui a une
mortalité moins sévère
ça c'est le contexte aujourd'hui depuis
le début du mois de mai on a comme vous
le savez une
diffusion au delà de la zone d'endémie
c'est déjà arrivé la particularité c'est
ces modes de transmission et je je je
laisserais détaillé spf mais la
particularité c'est que ça va avoir un
impact sur la présentation clinique
aujourd'hui et c'est inédit on a une
transmission interhumaine assez
dynamique dans une communauté
particulière avec des modes de
transmission qui sont essentiellement
les rapports sexuels dans le cadre de
multi partenariat
et saas revient sur un terrain qui est
assez
systématique on retrouve des hommes qui
sont en général jeunes et qui ont très
peu de comorbidité on a des patients qui
sont séropositifs au vih mais la plupart
sont très bien contrôlés ne présentent
pas dit mot des pressions nous n'avons
pas de forme grave et dans la population
d'aujourd'hui
ce sont des patients qui ne présente pas
de facteur de risque de gravité de cette
maladie qui est essentiellement les
enfants les femmes enceintes et les
personnes immunodéprimées
la particularité
clinique de cette sortie de la maladie
de sa zone d'endémie est lié
probablement aux modes de transmission
puisqu'on a des lésions qui sont
essentiellement en tout cas dans un
premier temps
génitales ou perry génitales
et qui vont évoluer aussi
avec la même chronologie classiquement
mais on voit régulièrement des
évolutions qui sont atypiques avec des
récurrences proche du de la première
entre guillemets floraison c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression que cliniquement
vous avez plusieurs
éruptions cutanées qui ne sont pas
décrites dans la maladie ainsi que deux
hommes dans emi qui pourrait laisser
envisager une physiopathologie
différentes ou deux pour qu'autant ciel
recontamination
par ailleurs par rapport à la
spécificité des modes de transmission on
a des cas plus fréquent de rectitude et
de pharyngite qui probablement sont
liées au mode de transmission quand on
ignore aujourd'hui les séquelles
potentielles au niveau fonctionnel
aujourd'hui on a en france de ce qu'on
peut en voir sur le dénominateur
en tout cas de l'expérience de biche
aida pitié on a à peu près la même
évaluation oui du malade c'est que la
gravité est faible mais autour d'eux un
panel de 500 patients diagnostiqués pour
bichat pitié on a plus de vingt-cinq
hospitalisation
ce n'est pas complètement négligeable
par contre il faut préciser que ce sont
des hospitalisations qui ne sont pas en
réanimation keane
bref pas le pronostic vital qui sont
essentiellement des atteintes oculaires
d'écart à titre d atteinte rectal ou des
surinfections bactériennes qui est sur
la zone d'endémie la principale cause de
gravité voire de décès sur un accès aux
soins qui est limité et un accès aux
antibiotiques qui est parfois restreint
voilà en gros pour la situation clinique
je peux dresser aujourd'hui avant les
les questions éventuelles
alors qui prend la suite sans santé
publique france vous avez un peu plus
facile si on va bosser un diaporama vous
souhaitez vous appuyez on le passe tout
de suite oui six bouquets matin le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc je vais vous dresser un
point de situation épidémiologique
voilà quelques diapos juste parce que ça
passe mieux avec des figures donc
diapositives suivante s'il vous plaît
si
positive voilà donc peut-être un mot
pour revenir sur l' alerte initiale 1
qui date de mai 2000 22 l'alertent a été
émise par les autorités sanitaires de
grande bretagne par un système européen
qui permet aux états membres et à la
grande bretagne également d'échanger des
messages d'information sanitaires de
manière rapide et donc ce message a été
reçu par la dgs et santé publique france
le samedi 14 mai et faisait état de deux
cas confirmé chez une mère et un
nouveau-né
d'infection à moncaut monkey pox avec un
cas index qui était le conjoint et
surtout sans notion de le voyage ni
contact avec des voyageurs
et ça c'était des kakis daté du 12 13
mai donc la date du 14 mai les anglais
rapporte aussi quatre cas confirmés chez
des hommes ayant des rapports sexuels
avec des hommes sans non plus notion de
voyage ni de contact avec des voyageurs
et donc c'était très fortement en faveur
d'une transmission autochtone sur le
territoire de grande bretagne
donc ce message a été bien reçu par nous
mêmes et nos collègues de la dgs nous
avons eu une première réunion de lundi
pour effectivement analyser ce signal
parce qu'ils étaient atypiques
les notifications précédente concerner
toutes des importations avec des gens
qui avaient en afrique le portugal
seconde herman a aussi confirmé ses
premiers cas au départ il faisait état
aussi de syndrome infectieux similaire
avec des lésions cutanées chez des
homosexuels masculins sans diagnostic
étiologique mais ils ont recherché
montcler pas que suite à l' alerte
anglaise et donc nous avons mis en place
dès le 17 mai une surveillance renforcée
sous surveillance en tension en fait ça
veut dire qu'en plus de la déclaration
obligatoire pour tous les orthodoxes
virus de la variole nous avons mis en
place une définition de cas spécifiques
et une conduite à tenir qui a été
diffusé aux cliniciens qui déclare
ensuite c'est carré au laboratoire est
le premier cas français a été déclarée
après diagnostic au cnr le 19 mai
diapositives suivante
et donc ça c'est la situation 4 juillet
tel que rapporté par l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé sur
la base des données remontées par les
pays et donc au 4 juillet plus de 6000
cas étaient recensés avec une très
grande majorité 4920 dans la région
europe de l' oms diapositives suivante
vous avez la même situation date du 7
juillet sur la base des données
colligées par le centre européen de
contrôle et de prévention des maladies
et qui fait état voilà de l'inventaire
du nombre de cas en europe et vous voyez
que les pays l'est principalement
concernés en date du 7 juillet sont
l'espagne l'allemagne la france le
portugal les pays-bas l'italie et la
belgique je ne cite que les pays qui ont
déclaré plus de 100k
diapositives suivante
vous avez ici la courbe épidémique sur
la base des mêmes données européennes
alors vous voyez qu'il ya une
progression régulière
il faut toutefois noter ne pas se fier à
l'apparence de stabilisation boîte de
décroissance sur les dernières semaines
puisque nous avons des délais de
diagnostic en moyenne de 7 jours et par
ailleurs les pays peuvent avoir des
délais de notification à le céder ces
variables je reviendrai sur ce qui est
la situation française juste après
diapositives suivante
juste pour vous illustrer un peu les
différences de dynamique par pays vous
avez au centre la courbe épidémique
française on va y revenir plus en
détails juste après et vous voyez que
les trois pays en eau sont l'angleterre
à gauche l'espagne au milieu et
l'allemagne à droite qui ont des
dynamiques un peu plus précoce qu'en
france et surtout beaucoup plus
importante
diapositives filantes
donc sur la base de nos données
nationales c'est le bilan que nous avons
arrêté hier 12 juillet à 14 heures ce
bilan sera mis en ligne après une autre
séance on avait recensé en france 900 12
cas confirmés dont 828 ont fait l'objet
d'une investigation par nos équipes et
celles des ars et ont été décrits au 11
juillet ce qu'on peut dire sur ces 15
c'est qu'ils ont en moyenne 36 ans d'âge
médian avec une vous voyez une
intervalle qui va de 19 à 84 ans pour
les quarts adultes on a aussi cinq
adultes féminin et deux cas pédiatriques
est effectivement parmi les hommes dont
l'orientation sexuelle est connue 97 %
sont des hommes ayant des relations
sexuelles avec les hommes et 75 %
d'entre eux sont des dans un contexte de
multi partenariat c'est à dire avec au
moins deux partenaires rapportés dans
les trois semaines avant le début des
symptômes dans la plupart des cas ces
cas ne peuvent pas identifier la
personne qui les aurait contaminé
diapositives suivante en termes de
répartition géographique de ces 8 124
cas décrit auront juillet vous voyez que
l'essentiel et est diagnostiquée en
région ile-de-france 517 sur ce bilan
mais on voit une augmentation régulière
de cas déclarés en région auvergne
rhône-alpes et paca occitanie et
nouvelle aquitaine sans doute aussi à la
faveur des migrations estivales
diapositives suivante donc ça c'est la
courbe épidémique française encore une
fois j'insiste
les dernières semaines ne sont pas
consolidées en termes de données nous
avons aujourd'hui des diagnostics médian
de six jours en france il a beaucoup
diminué j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que
l'épidémie est encore active la date de
début des signes du premier cas c'était
le 7 mai et le dernier cas recensé dans
ce bilan le 7 juillet diapositives
suivante en termes de principes aussi me
rapporter
80 % déclarent des éruptions génitaux
annales 73% une éruption sur une autre
partie du corps 70% de la fière des
adénopathies ou des maux de gorge 5%
sont immunodéprimés 211 soit 26% sont
séropositifs au vih
et pour les non porteurs du vih 403 soit
70% sont sous prête comme je les dis la
prophylaxie
pré-exposition pour le vih
le délai mais nantes diagnostic qu'il
est de 6 jours mais il a diminué il
était très jour en semaine 18 il est de
4 jours aujourd'hui donc ça montre bien
qu' aujourd'hui l'accès au test
est beaucoup plus fluide qu'au tout
début on a quelques hospitalisations
rapportées effectivement comme le
rappelait le professeur xavier lescure
pour des gestions de douleurs parfois
intenses quelques surinfections
bactériennes des mesures d'isolement
parfois l'analyse est en cours dont je
n'ai pas de données plus précises à ce
stade mais nous pourrons vous les
communiquer ultérieurement aucun décès
n'a été recensé dans les carcans c
est donc pour conclure avant de laisser
la parole à mon collègue françois beck
voilà les actions de santé publique
france aujourd'hui se décline sur
plusieurs axes surveillance
investigations c'est à la base est la
source des données que je vous ai montré
contribution à l'expertisé lien avec la
recherche
on a des relations quotidiennes au
niveau national avec les cliniciens avec
des équipes de recherche notamment des
modélisateurs pour travailler sur la
dynamique épidémique avec la nrf c'est
mieux sur certains projets de recherche
on partage des données bien évidemment
est aussi partage de données avec
l'europe puisque toutes nos données de
surveillance nationales alimente les
travaux du centre européen de contrôle
et prévention des maladies ainsi qu'avec
l' oms
l'appui aux décideurs il est quotidien
nous transmettons ces bilans de manière
quotidienne le nombre de cas depuis le
19 mai à la direction générale de la
santé
les analyses de sur le suivi des
contacts sont en cours pour notamment
voir quelles sont leurs caractéristiques
et puis bien sûr
santé publique france dans sa dimension
établissements pharmaceutiques participe
à la gestion du stock des doses de
vaccins d'antiviraux et aux schémas
logistiques d'approvisionnement et donc
sur la prévention je laisserais mon
collègue françois beck que vous
détailler les actions en cours à partir
de la diapositive suivantes
1 à mal après nantes mais d'amener et
messieurs les sénateurs donc je vais
vous parler des mesures de prévention
qui ont été prises donc à santé publique
france dans une logique de continuum oui
d'accord donc les actions de prévention
les actions de prévention que nous avons
mis en place sa santé publique france
ont été longs étaient dans un continuum
avec les données que le dr coignard
vient de vous présenter et puisqu'il ya
un point qui est très important c'est de
le ciblage des populations qu'on va
essayer d'atteindre avec ces différentes
mesures de prévention donc il est très
important pour nous de voir comment
l'épidémie évolue et comment en
particulier les profils des gens qui
sont atteints évolue donc
nous avons pu nous appuyer sur un
dispositif qui existait la santé
publique france 2 puis 2016 qui
s'appelle sexo safe qu'un dispositif à
la fois digital est présent sur le
terrain dans les milieux de la
communauté lgbt et donc dès le début 20
mai on a pu démarrer grâce à ce
dispositif un premier post sur les
réseaux sociaux et ensuite on a mis en
place une une faq le 27 mai il ya eu un
article
sur le site sexo sete.fr
complètement dédié à la variole du singe
pour expliquer parce qu'on savait à
cette époque là et puis au fur et à
mesure on a mis à disposition un certain
nombre d'outils pour les acteurs de
terrain pour les ars mais aussi pour les
associations en contact avec les
différents lieux de consommation
sexuelle notamment
donc on a conçu des affiches une fiche
conseil dédié au personnel des
établissements les plus concernés par la
part la variole du singe et puis un
flyer pour
pour diffusion dans les lieux de
consommation sexuelle et surtout pour
les les marches des fiertés qui avait
lieu entre fin mai et début juillet dans
enfin dans tout dans beaucoup de grandes
villes françaises donc c'était très
important en parallèle donc on a fait un
certain nombre de campagne sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis à partir de mi
juin on est passé à une communication
d'intensité plus forte avec une campagne
d'affichage plus soutenue dans les les
bars restaurants et clubs gay ou gay
friendly
une campagne digitale qui a été plus
intense aussi que s'appuyer sur les
réseaux sociaux et les sites
communautaires notamment committed mr
bambi
et puis sur les applications de
rencontres aussi puisque l'enjeu se
situe et beaucoup là je pense par
exemple à ornette ou grinder est ensuite
il ya eu un partenariat avec d'autres
médias communautaires des radios
notamment radio fg et ji hwan radio
à partir de maintenant et depuis le donc
le oui tu sais ces temps de
communication avaient tous un coeur de
messages qui étaient autour du repérage
des symptômes qui ont pu évoluer
d'ailleurs au cours de cours de
l'épidémie sur la conduite à tenir et
sur l'appel à un professionnel de santé
donc le troisième temps de communication
va être au tour à la fois du repérage
des symptômes mais aussi de la promotion
de la vaccination depuis le l'avis rendu
par la chasse la has et puis l'ouverture
d'une ligne de la distance monkey pox
info service
voilà donc on continue la campagne
digitale avec ses différentes
adaptations
et puis pour le terrain a été conçu une
affiche pour les lieux de vaccination
une nouvelle fiche conseils pour les
personnels des lieux de convivialité et
puis un certain nombre de flyers qui est
donc évoque en plus le la vaccination
pour ce qui concerne les populations
autre que hsh donc hommes qui ont des
rapports sexuels avec d'autres hommes on
est aussi en train de travailler à des
fiches pour le le site internet
vaccination info service qui lui est
acquis à la fois à destination des pros
de santé et du grand public alors en
termes de performances on a donc une
campagne qui a réussi à atteindre de
nombreux
enfin de nombreuses personnes dans sa
cible puisque il ya eu plus de 200000
clics sur les bannières qui ont pu
apparaître sur des sur des sites ciblés
et donc ça c'est un indicateur qui est
très intéressant parce que c'est un
geste que fait
le visiteur internet pour aller vers
l'information qu'on lui propose et puis
donc on s'est appuyé sur plus de 300
établissements ce qui représentait à peu
près un million d'occasions de voir les
affiches qu'on diffusait et puis on a un
certain nombre d'autres indicateurs sur
lesquels je pourrais revenir juste un
tout dernier mot pour vous parler de
monkey pox info service donc c'est une
ligne qui est ouverte depuis aujourd'hui
vous voyez le numéro qui s'affiche ici
elle est ouverte de 8h à 23h tous les
jours de la semaine et donc c'est un
dispositif qui est extrêmement
intéressant pour compléter toutes les
autres actions prévention puisque ça
permet aux gens qui sont dans l'angoissé
dans l'inquiétude d'avoir un
interlocuteur
tout tout de suite et donc c'est très
complémentaire avec tout le reste de ce
qu'on a proposé
là et maintenant la dgs
merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs en complément de ce que mes
collègues m'ont dit je vais essayer de
vous expliquer ce qu'on a fait depuis la
lettre que vous a
résumé bono coignard et dans quel esprit
on y travailler qu'elles soient les
perspectives qu'on se donne en terme de
gestion peut-être deux messages pour
commencer d'abord sur la variole du
singe
rappeler que ça s'appelle la variole du
singe mais c'est pas la variole c'est un
cousin de la variole et ça peut avoir
avec le singe a été découvert chez les
singes le singe peut être hôte de cette
maladie mais le réservoir animal et
c'est important ce sont plutôt les
petits rongeurs et évidemment on a des
dangereux qu'on travaille avec land
cesse et les autorités vétérinaires sur
ce sujet là le deuxième le deuxième
message à passer en introduction c'est
que comme nom très bien expliqué les uns
les autres il faut qu'on soit excellent
clair que ce n'est pas une maladie des
hommes ayant des relations sexuelles
avec des hommes mais que actuellement
l'épidémie que nous connaissons dans les
pays de l'hémisphère nord et en europe
est centré sur cette communauté
aujourd'hui et que ça peut diffuser
au-delà de ce cercle et qu' il n'y a pas
de didier houssin krasic sur cette
commune était là
avec cette maladie là et donc il faut il
faut le dire de manière très claire
ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir ça a
été un petit peu rappelé ce sont des cas
importés depuis les zones d'endémie vers
nos pays il ya eu des cas ces dernières
années vers les etats unis vers le
royaume-uni beaucoup avec les liens avec
le nigeria il sera elle en 2018
singapour en 2010 9 des événements
d'introduction rêver avec des fréquences
répété qu'ils augmentent parce que les
l'augmentation du trafic aérien et
mondiale augmente et donc que la
probabilité de ce type d'événement grand
ce qu'on n'avait pas vu ce sont des
circulations active au delà de quelques
cas secondaires éventuellement qui se
diffuser à large échelle et donc c'est
ça que on a vu avec la détection du
premier cas en france
le 19 mai
à partir de ce premier cas la première
chose qu'on a fait c'est qui est très
classique c'est qu'on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle une stratégie et autour du
risque épidémique et biologiques on
appelle dans le jargon le reb et qui
vise à avoir une stratégie d'endiguement
autour des premiers cas d'une maladie
qui ne circulent pas de manière
autochtones dans notre pays alors c'est
assez contraignant c'est à dire qu'avec
santé publique france on l'a on a
utilisé la définition de cas qu'ils ont
élaboré une conduite à tenir qui vise à
l'isolément des cas pendant 21 jours
c'est long
à réaliser des investigations
à la fois en aval pour trouver les
éventuels cas secondaires
possiblement en amont aussi pour aller
chercher les lieux de contamination et
les circonstances de contamination et
éventuellement les les documenter et
voir pouvoir avoir des actions quand on
trouve ce type ce type d'événement et
que ça concerne plusieurs personnes mais
c'est évidemment pour écouter en
ressources l'autre enjeu dans cette
galère c'est d'alerter les cliniciens
avec un certain nombre de messages et on
s'est appuyé notamment évident par nos
messages que vous connaissez depuis la
crise qu vite qu'ils sont les marchés
des gestes urgents mais aussi via une
mission qui s'appelle la mission corrèze
coordination du risque épidémique et
biologie qui travaillent de manière très
opérationnelle avec les cliniciens
réseau de cliniciens pour essayer de
diffuser les choses et tout simplement
et le professeur lescure vous le
confirmera il ya assez peu de
spécialistes en france qui ont eu à
connaître des cas de monkey pox avant
cette émergence là et donc voir à quoi
ça ressemble voir que les lésions qui
sont décrites et ça a été parfaitement
rappeler ne sont pas exactement celles
qu'on trouve en une de google images et
donc on peut passer à côté du diagnostic
pour plein de raisons il ya toute cette
phase d' alerte de sensibilisation un
travail qui a été fait notamment au
niveau de l'iconographie pour montrer ce
que c'était ses lésions et commencer à
les repérer et sensibiliser également
dans les populations dont on commençait
à sentir que elles étaient les plus
ciblés passer ces informations-là
commencé à faire du repérage de casse
qui permet ensuite de voir une
augmentation du nombre de cas et
l'augmentation du nombre de cas c'est
évidemment une circulation virale qui
augmente mais c'est aussi
un taux de détection qui augmente on
reperd plus de cas parce qu'il ya plus
de gens sensibilisés
on a mis assez rapidement en place une
vaccination des contacts à risque une
vaccination post exposition
premier cas le 19 mai on à la vie de la
chaise qui sort le 24 mai et sur cette
base là on prend à m'arrêter sur le
fondement de l'article l 31 1 31-1 qui
est bondé parce que le vaccin américains
gênés hausse à une am aux états unis sur
l'indication monkey pox européen est
néanmoins c'est un très bon vaccin très
utile dans cette indication là et donc
ça permet de l'utiliser donc ça a été
mise en oeuvre assez directement l'avis
de la has a été ensuite complété le vin
le 20 juin pour préciser les indications
chez les enfants et chez les personnes
qui avaient déjà été immunisés contre la
variole quand elle était plus jeune et
depuis le début de l'accident à sion il
rit on est à plus de 1000 injection qui
ont été réalisés on a également saisi
plusieurs fois le haut conseil de la
santé publique pour nous aider à
élaborer et diffuser des records nation
recommandation sur la conduite à tenir
autour des cas et des sujets contacts
recommandations spécifiques pour les
personnes ayant un risque de formule
rave recommandations enfin plus
récemment sur les mesures de prévention
et les gestes barrière spécifique pour
cet évident à mantoue ça se fait avec
des échanges continus avec les
associations et ce dès cette étape
la documentation des cas qui a été fait
par son public france et les agences
régionales de santé et les échanges avec
les cliniciens ont permis de comprendre
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est à
dire une circulation particulière dans
cette épidémie si dans la communauté des
personnes hsh multipartenaires
avec une localisation assez spécifique
des lésions ça a été rappelé par le
professeur exclure et les circonstances
de transmission qui a priori sont plutôt
très majoritairement des contacts très
rapproché à partir de là
ce qu'on peut dire c'est ce n'est pas
une infection sexuellement transmissible
au sens strict médical du terme mais qu'
il ya un certain nombre de facteurs qui
font que ça s'en rapproche
et donc tout l'enjeu en termes de
gestion à partir de ce moment là au
moment où ce tableau et merde c'est de
basculer de notre cadre risques
épidémiques et biologiques que je vous
expliquais à un cadre qui se rapproche
plus d'un gestion infectiologie qu plus
classique avec une forte composante de
santé sexuelle et reproductive et donc
c'est ça qu'on est en train de
travailler que je vous détailler
maintenant
sur la prise en charge des cas au départ
était centrée sur les établissements de
santé de référence et établissements
habilités par les ars pour la gestion du
risque épidémique et biologiques on a
ouvert la prise en charge au départ
l'ensemble des services de maladies
infectieuses et par suite on commence à
voir la prise en charge en ville avec
les cegid
les cegid alors vous allez m'aider mais
c'est les centres gratuite d'information
de dépistage et je n'ai pas le dernier
des et je suis sûr que vous vous lavez
diagnostic et des visages diagnostics
sont des centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit voilà pour le diagnostic des
siestes
fait vraiment des centres dédiés à la
santé sexuelle et vous voyez que c'est
comme ça qu'on fait la bascule du du
risque épidémique vert vers une prise en
charge plus large et plus et plus
facilitantes et
c'est
de ce sont des centres de premiers
recours que les gens ont l'habitude de
consulter donc c'est bien là où ils vont
donc c'est on a tout intérêt à ce que le
système se met en place vers la vers la
porte d'entrée naturelle pour ces
populations là et c'est bien ce qu'on
essaye de travailler on a passé aussi
labé le message que le premier réflexe
est tous le même c'est le médecin
traitant aussi et s'il ya un doute le 15
c'est aussi fait pour orienter et
évidemment toutes les plates formes
qu'elles sont parfaitement les
informations vers où orienter les
patients
de des échanges avec les cliniciens là
aussi le conserver sur pourra vous en
parler est revenu au premier plan et
avec les associations aussi je dois dire
elle le fait que les lésions faisait
horriblement bas et donc évidemment on
est très sensible à cette
problématique et donc on a saisi les
sociétés savantes compétente pour
disposer d'un avis sur la prise en
charge spécifique de la douleur dans le
monkey pox on attend leur retour
incessamment sous peu et ont évidemment
on va diffuser sa l'ensemble des
communautés clinique pour que ça puisse
faire et organiser des filières de prise
en charge spécifique de la douleur y
compris pour des patients qui ne
nécessiterait pas une hospitalisation au
sens strict mais
il faut qu on traite ce sujet là et on
est en train de le traiter on fait
évoluer progressivement la définition de
cas et la conduite à tenir parce que
maintenant qu'on a clairement un tableau
on n'a peut-être pas besoin de
documenter aussi complètement tous les
cas mais un échantillon de cas et on n'a
peut-être plus besoin de tester tous les
cas lorsque le diagnostic clinique est
absolument certain et évident est que
l'ensemble des diagnostics différentiels
et notamment les ist ont été éliminés
par ailleurs puisque c'est bien
l'ensemble de la politique il faut
traiter sur le diagnostic pareil bascule
du raid vers quelque chose de plus
communautaire au départ ce sont les
laboratoires de niveau p3 dans les es r
qui sont habilités et vous savez que
comme le monkey pox est proche de la
variole
ça fait l'objet de réglementations
particulières avec l'année c'est mon à
faciliter au maximum les choses mais il
ya des autorisations à obtenir pour
qu'un laboratoire et le droit de détenir
ce type de prélèvement
on est en train d'ouvrir sa l'ensemble
des laboratoire p3 de hospitalier et le
centre national de référence déploie la
technique diagnostic et assiste ces
laboratoires dans le déploiement des
techniques diagnostiques et on est en
train de travailler aussi l ouverture op
3 de ville et ça nécessite un certain
nombre d'heures travaillées le vendeur
donc on a saisi la haute autorité de
santé pour
l'inscription à la nomenclature des
actes de biologie médicale et on attend
là aussi leur avis rapidement pour
pouvoir déployer sa en vide on a eu un
avis de la société française de
microbiologie qui nous indiquent que sar
est préférable de rester en niveau p 3
compte tenu de la pathogènes nécessité
de cet agent mais que dans certains
territoires où dansaient dans certaines
situations s'il ya une perte de chance
pour le patient on peut dégrader un
petit peu ce qu'on appelle paie de plus
je rentre pas dans le détail vous m'en
excuserez mais ce qui nous permet
d'avoir un peu nous notamment dans
certains territoires pour quand même
avoir la technique diagnostic et là
aussi on y travaille
enfin c'est encore un peu tôt mais on
travaille d'ores et déjà avec l'asm pour
identifier les fabricants 2 trod de
tests rapides d'orientation diagnostique
de pouvoir en disposer de pouvoir
évaluer et notamment avec la nes et
mieux les performances d'autres états
parce qu'évidemment il n'est pas
question de déployer des thèses qui
n'auraient pas de bonnes performances et
qui induit en erreur sur le diagnostic
et donc on espère que à moyen terme et
arrivera à développer on pense
évidemment que si on avait des trod de
bonnes performances et que ça puisse
être positionnés dans les fameux cegid
dont on parlait tout à l'heure on a
quelque chose qui serait pas mal en
termes de diagnostic voilà un peu la
perspective et j'en viens à la
vaccination préventive et je sais que le
sujet vous intéresse
on a saisi oui je lis un peu la presse
et les réseaux sociaux aussi donc c'est
la saisine de la haute autorité de santé
oms la fête le 1er juillet la haute
autorité de santé nous a rendu son avis
le 8 juillet en nous indiquant trois
indications principales qui sont les
hommes ayant des relations sexuelles
avec les hommes multipartenaires et les
personnes trans multipartenaires les
gérants de lieu de convivialité avec
consommation sexuelle et puis les
personnes en situation de prostitution
et en nous indiquant également
marginalement qu'elle ne retenait pas
d'indication de prioriser pour la
vaccination des soignants mais que
au cas par cas pour des soignantes
particulièrement exposés parce qu'ils
voient des patients monkey pox tous les
jours ou qu'ils ont à manipuler des
échantillons de tous les jours ça peut
se faire au cas par cas le dernier point
et c'est important dans dans la
discussion c'est que la haute autorité
ne nous dit aussi bien sûr que cette
indication là elle ne se fait pas au
détriment
de l'indication précédente qui est la
vaccination post-exposition sont deux
choses différentes mais deux indications
coexistent et la vaccination post
exposition est prioritaire sur la
vaccination préventive
puisqu'on est en fait à face à un risque
immédiat vertueux sans risque autant
c'est
donc suite à la réception de la ville le
8 juillet il a été annoncé le jour même
que la vie elle est suivie on a envoyé
des messages à l'ensemble des ars pour
leur indiquer la vie et qui fait qu'on
travaille à l'élargissement des centres
de vaccination ils se sont mis en ordre
de marche tout de suite on avait déjà un
petit peu anticipé
et on a travaillé bien sûr avec santé
publique france dans sa composante est
bien établissements pharmaceutiques avec
l'asm pour essayer de d'organiser le
schéma logistique et puis lever
l'ensemble des francs technique qui peut
y avoir notamment les les conditions de
conservation et de transport de ce type
de vaccin sont pas sont pas complètement
simple et donc en fait très attention
parce qu'il s'agit pas non plus de faire
n'importe quoi avec ces vaccins
on a on a fait sortir un nouvel arrêté l
31 1 31-1 le dimanche 10 pour permettre
de lever l'ensemble des freins
réglementaires qui nous gênait pour
déployer cette vaccination
donc là aussi extrêmement de manière
extrêmement volontariste à dire que on a
arrêté qu'il n'y a pas besoin de faire
depuis une pharmacie hospitalière ce
qu'on appelle une rétrocession
nominatives si on veut vacciner par
exemple dans les cegid on a levé
le fait que les centres de vaccination
ne pouvait pas vaccinés pour ce type de
dérives de vaccin puisque elle ne
pouvait vacciner que pour les
indications du calendrier vaccinal il
n'est pas dans le calendrier vaccinal
et puis on a rappelé que
c'était un versant à prescription
médicale mais que bien sûr les
infirmiers et les infirmières pouvait
réaliser l'injection sur sur
prescription médicale
les airs ont travaillé là aussi à
l'ouverture des centres à l'heure où je
vous parle on a plus de 70 centres de
vaccination qui sont référencés
elles sont référencés sur les sites des
agences régionales de santé et on les a
agrégé au niveau du site sante.fr où il
ya un onglet maintenant dédié monkey pox
nour sante.fr slash monkey pox de
regarder ce matin il y avait 72 centres
évidemment les peler de rendez-vous
commence c'est ce qu'on avait dit ça
commencerait à partir de cette semaine
et en plus on a une semaine avec le 14
juillet au milieu s'est pas complètement
simple est idéale mais on fait avec et
il ya des premières des premiers créneau
qui sont ouverts d'autres qui vont
suivre et puis on va on va arriver à une
vitesse de croisière j'espère assez
rapidement
maintenant je voudrais quand même
souligner le fait qu'on est parmi les
premiers pays à faire cette vaccination
préventive le royaume-uni le canada et
l'allemagne ont commencé mais on est on
est dans les mêmes temps et on est très
peu de pays à le faire à ce stade
l'enjeu ça a été des vendredis de
redimensionner les stocks qui étaient
prépositionnés dans les régions
puisqu'on avait pré-positionné des doses
pour la vaccination des sujets contacts
et qu'il faut augmenter ça donc c'est
des circuits logistiques importants et
on y travaille et on continue à
consolider et à amplifier les circuits
d'approvisionnement sur la communication
peut-être un mot parce que c'est là une
question que vous me posez sur sur les
stocks ils sont couverts par le secret
défense donc j'ai vécu cette question là
j'en suis désolé c'est quoi la défense
c'est la composition et le capacitaire
du stock et donc j'en prendrais pas
évidemment pour les raisons goût vous
comprenez dans le détail sur la
communication
les collègues de santé publique france
en ont beaucoup parlé mais je voudrais
quand même insisté sur le fait qu on a
un dialogue très rapprochés avec les
associations et un dialogue que je
trouve de qualité je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle en ramenant tout cas de qualité
et hebdomadaire on a une visio
conférence hebdomadaire depuis le début
de cette alerte avec elle pour expliquer
ce qu'on fait et prendre les remonter
terran et ce qui va ce qui va pas et on
se dit assez franchement les choses le
numéro un le numéro vert qui est ouvert
depuis aujourd'hui et dont je rappelle
le numéro 0 805 90 80 69 et puis tous
les travaux qui ont été rappelés par
françois beck sur l'année donc voila
vous voyez on a fait beaucoup de choses
dans un temps restreint parce qu'il faut
toujours se méfier du bief historique
finalement ça fait qu'un mois et demi
que cette alerte a commencé c'est un
temps relativement courte
je tiens ici de l'envoi rendre hommage
aux équipes qui travaillent avec moi sur
ce sujet là elles sont totalement
mobilisées tard le soir le week-end
compris on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour
déployer au maximum
les choses le plus vite possible
j'espère qu'on va arriver à lever tous
les freins qui reste en tout cas vous
pouvez être assurés qu'on est totalement
déterminée pour lutter face à cette
nouvelle épidémie et j'espère que tout
ce que nous avons appris dans le cadre
de l'accord vide va nous servir pour
gérer ça au mieux
merci beaucoup donc nous allons passer
de cette présentation nous allons passer
aux différentes questions
corinne imbert
mélanie pochette
merci à la présidente merci messieurs
pour pour vos explosé
j'aurais évidemment plusieurs questions
si j'ai un temps imparti madame la
présidente à la fois
non papa pas tout mais non mais j'ai
quand même une sélection de plusieurs
questions même si certains sujets
évidemment ont été abordés par les
différentes prises de parole
tout d'abord concernant la maladie et sa
diffusion en france pour voir
nombre de cas recensés à la fois je veux
dire relativement modeste puisque on
partait de 500 ko au 5 juillet mais avec
quelque part un emballement puisqu'on
est à plus de 915 quelques jours ainsi
jours plus tard
quelles craintes avez-vous en termes de
d'emballement de cette épidémie et en
terme de mortalité j'ai bien entendu à
ce jour il n'y a pas de de décès liés à
cette pathologie
en france on a vu qu'il y avait un taux
de mortalité important même s'ils
étaient plus faibles en afrique de
l'ouest
malgré tout ça fait ça fait un taux de
en afrique de l'ouest 10% est ce que
vous craignez que ce taux de 10% puisse
atteindre les patients dans notre dans
notre pays
dont ces noms que vous nous avez ce
chiffre de 912 ce cas est ce qu il fait
état de la réalité de l'épidémie et
égouts estimez vous que certains cas
sont asymptomatiques et non au mal
dépistée et même si j'ai entendu que le
délai de diagnostic était réduit
et si
le déploiement de trog étaient en cours
pour avoir donc d'aider des tests
rapides d'orientation diagnostique est
ce que vous pouvez nous présenter des
mesures prises pour favoriser le
dépistage au delà de cette fraude
concernant les traitements préventifs ou
curatifs
effectivement la question des vaccins
nous intéresse fortement
comment expliquer le décalage même si
vous l'avez dit monsieur de la direction
générale de la
santé vous avez souligné que la france
faisait partie des premiers pays à en
ouvrir la vaccination pré-exposition
après le canada le royaume uni
l'allemagne mais on a un petit décalage
bien sûr vous avez certainement on a
attendu l'avis de la haute autorité de
santé mais comment vous expliquer ce
décalage est alors même si j'ai aussi
bien entendu nous l'avons tous entendue
que le la notion de stocks étaient
couverts par le secret défense ou mais
quand même permettait nous nous
interroger sur le stock dit suffisant
alors vous allez peut-être pas me
répondre parce que vous me direz secret
défense mais j'ai quand même entendu que
vous nous expliquer que la vaccination
post exposition devait rester
prioritaire
par rapport à la vaccination
pré-exposition il me semble que c'est ce
que vous avez dit voilà donc ça veut
dire que si elle reste prioritaire c'est
qu'à un moment donné on va gérer des
stocks sauf erreur de ma part sinon on
se poserait pas la question ou alors
celle là
l'épidémie va s'enflammer et d'où les
ces mesures mise mise en place
la haute autorité de santé recommande
deux injections ce jour à 28 jours des
cas
ce délai entre deux injections pouvant
entraîner jusqu'à quelques semaines je
sais exactement en face je cite la haute
autorité de santé ça veut dire quoi que
quelques semaines et là encore est ce
que c'est pas une façon de gérer des
stocks à
l' agence européenne era aurait passé
des commandes de vaccins
alors peut-être que j'aurai encore
secret défense mais la france at elle
souscrit à ces commandes groupe au
niveau européen et le gouvernement
français basile réalistes ils
décommandent parallèle
et concernant les vaccins utilisés
pouvez vous nous donner des informations
quant à leur efficacité
et comment cela a souvent été l'objet de
craintes dans le cas de la pandémie de
kobe quant à leur innocuité c'est ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de ces vaccins
voilà des barrages la vaccination ni de
france semble difficile est ce un
problème de logistique ou est-ce qu'on
en revient un problème de manque de
doses accessible et à quelle date des
vaccinations seront elles possibles en
région voilà je vais m'arrêter là
voilà oui m'a dit elle avait
l'impression je m'arrête là je vous
remercie très bien les bonnes questions
on va prendre deux autres intervenants
et ensuite on répondra et on prend enfin
une autre salve de questions florence
lassarade berlin je me oui merci pour
compléter un petit peu les questions
médicales moi qui suis pédiatre et qui
sait quand maternité en redoutent en
redoutent le virus de l'herpès génital
et des dégâts qui peut produire chez le
nouveau né ce qui a déjà un protocole
qui a été donné pour la femme enceinte
qui pourraient être porteuses de de
lésions génitales
suspecte est ce qu'on fait une
césarienne un peu
systématiquement est ce que ces sujets
ont été évoqués
deuxièmement
moi aussi j'avais une question sur le
délai des faces d'efficacité de la
vaccination
est ce que on peut envisager la
vaccination de la femme enceinte je ne
le pense pas mais vous le dirai et enfin
tu en connais dans la rubrique
vaccination puisse manger beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus avec l'opex à propos
de
deux vaccins avisé oro génitales est ce
que le vaccin du papillomavirus
se diffuse ou s.koné on est encore à
justement est-ce que le vaccin du
papillomavirus a pas été victimes de
l'épidémie de covin et et sa publicité
également puisqu'on avait un vaccin à
viser vraiment génitales et bernard
jomier est ce qu'on pourra voir les
slides ont été présentes merci censure
des métalleux et le professeur lescure
nous enverra
merci maladie longuement pas
bon mais question sont assez on va dire
similaires ou à celle de corinne imbert
mais
de façon moins diplomate quel comme
d'habitude ce que je trouve que le
discours que notamment la direction
générale de la santé nous a offert est
quand même un très beau discours bien
lissés mais ne correspond pas exactement
à la réalité
de fait du déroulement des faits vous
avez
rappelé avec justesse que le premier
avis de la haute autorité de santé la
première recommandation ces femmes et
autour de la question de la variole du
singe le 20 23 24 mai à ce moment là et
il est marquant de constater que depuis
alors il ya eut saisi et les
recommandations vous ne l'avez décrit
mais fin mai c'est le moment où
l'allemagne elle elle commandait 240000
vaccin pour sa population
c'était femmes et voilà et vous à la
question des commandes de vaccins nous
n'avons toujours pas de réponse alors où
on a besoin on espère qu'on va l'avoir
ce matin parce qu'on est le 12 ou 13
juillet
mais pour le moment il n'y a eu aucune
réponse à cette question voilà le
décalage
coup créé et si on reprend mais je vais
être court parce que la présente nous a
demandé d'être court les chronologies
sur les états unis ou sur le canada sur
les autres grands pays sont concernés
est à peu près du même ordre on est par
rapport à ces pays largement en retard
comme d'habitude
deuxième point
la situation actuelle pour nous pour
l'évaluer nous avons besoin premièrement
d'avoir des prévisions des
épidémiologistes et ce qui est marquant
c'est que on en a pas alors est ce que
c'est le nombre de facteurs
d'incertitude qui rend les prévisions
trop complexes avec des écarts qui
serait telle qu'on ne pourrait pas en
tirer une leçon en termes après deux
mesures à prendre mais en tout état de
cause
on a on a dans les saisies d'avis qu'ils
nous ont été exposés on n'a pas entendu
de saisie d'avis sur les prévisions
épidémiologique et sur les îles et
notamment sur les données précisent que
demandé corinne imbert
j'ai donc vous poser juste quatre
questions 1 celle des prévisions
épidémiologique 2 la question du nombre
de vaccins qui sont disponibles pour la
population générale et personne ici ne
vous demande quelles sont les stocks de
vaccins qui relèvent de la sécurité
nationale nous on ne peut pas opposer le
secret défense à la population générale
pour savoir quels sont les vaccins qui
sont disponibles pour la population
générale
ça ce n'est pas du relève ça ne ressort
pas de la sécurité nationale et de la
défense et cet argument la dgs il est
pour moi irrecevable troisièmement donc
les commandes de vaccins quand avez-vous
commandé des vaccins et quelques ailes
nombre de vaccins avez vous commandez et
quatrièmement le dispositif
d'information en direction des
populations donc un travail effectué
avec un certain nombre d'associations
notamment communautaires mais on
aimerait avoir plus d'informations sur
le dispositif d'information
sur
de la population sur la variole du singe
je remercie
répondre à ces questions en bon
professeur lescure je vous propose de
démarrer sur des questions qui vous
concerne et puis on prendra à suivre
je vais aller vite
pour nous répondre néanmoins je suis un
ami a les réponses sur glace charte
éthique
question
vous annoncer des chiffres qui je pense
qu'il faut être très modeste avec cette
maladie qui est extrêmement mal connu et
probablement décrite dans des conditions
d'accès au diagnostic et aux soins qui
sont incomparables avec ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui et qui permettent
probablement qu'ils induisent
probablement une approximation
importante
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas que la
mortalité
sur dans nos pays soient celles de 10%
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on observe
avec des milliers de patients qui ont
été identifiées il n'y a pas de décès
sous contrôle de spf aujourd'hui ni en
france ni dans d'autres pays de la zone
nord est dont + compte plus qu on a plus
de sept ou huit mille cas documentés ça
vous donne une petite idée de la
différence qu'il ya entre la mortalité
annoncé en avant en afrique de l'ouest
pour les 10% est ce qu'on observe ici je
ne crois pas que ce soit lié uniquement
au terrain des patients qui sont touchés
chez nous qui n'ont pas de facteur de
risque de formes graves que je vous ai
décrit c'est qu'ils sont les enfants les
femmes enceintes et les personnes
immunodéprimées je pense qu'il ya une
question dénominateur et de difficultés
a estimé dans les pays du sud la
létalité précise de la maladie
la deuxième question par rapport à la
crainte vis-à-vis de la diffusion je
pense que spf ou la dgs pourra avoir des
éléments de réponse ce qui est sûr c'est
que
si on a la réponse que je viens de vous
donner sur la gravité ou la mortalité
pourrait éventuellement différé si
l'épidémie venait se diffuser chez des
personnes à risque de formes graves
enfants femmes enceintes mais déprimé
donc ça proment c'est vrai que en termes
de de stratégie on veut éviter la
diffusion au delà de cette communauté en
partie est en grande partie à cause de
ces raisons-là
la caisse si on est et la question
pardon par rapport au dépistage et au
délai du diagnostic je pense que 1
peut-être aspects fausse y aura des
éléments de réponse 1
les circuits sont mis en place
progressivement l'offre au début comme
vous l'expliqué le docteur clément
lazarus était centrée sur les
établissements de santé de référence et
donc il ya eu un engorgement assez
rapide par rapport au nombre de nombre
de cas qui étaient essentiellement
centrés sur l'île de france le
déploiement d'autres centres pouvant
effectuer le diagnostic a permis de
réduire le délai de diagnostic et
l'autre raison aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
un diagnostic qui est permis sur une
approche clinique dans des équipes
expérimentées on n'a plus besoin de
faire une documentation virologique
pour les traitements effectivement on a
des traitements c'est pour ça que d'un
point de vue sanitaire on n'est pas très
inquiet d'une part parce que je vous ai
dit que la transmission interhumaine
était très faible dans les zones
d'endémie est donc au-delà des modes de
transmission spécifique décrit dans
cette communauté je ne pense pas que la
diffusion en population générale soit à
craindre dans les proportions
inquiétantes et puis on a des outils
thérapeutiques curatif
on al tecau viry maths qui est un
traitement oral anti viral on a le bras
ainsi d'offrir qui est aussi un
traitement antiviral en termes de
disponibilité pour le moment les
contraintes sont en train de se réduire
mais on pourra très prochainement avoir
accès à ces médicaments
dont l'efficacité
semble
intéressante assez puissante en termes
d'effets antiviral mais qui sont issus
de données animales avec une tolérance
qui allaient qui semble correct
et pour
vos questions spécifiques sur les
populations particulières femmes
enceintes et enfants
le thé cauvery mater indiqué à partir de
13 kg de poids corporel environ deux ans
lebrun sido faut virer indiqué dès la
naissance et chez la femme enceinte on
peut utiliser les immunoglobulines anti
vaccine qu'ils ont mais avec
probablement ici aussi un accès
difficile mais toutes ces questions
étaient anti
je pense que sur l'efficacité vaccinale
on a peu de données sur
le vaccin
vis-à-vis de monkey pox que celle vaccin
antivariolique classique elle est
estimée autour de 85% dans les limites
des de la robustesse des informations et
des données qu'on on peut avoir on sait
sur la vaccination antivariolique que la
mémoire de la vaccination et donc
l'efficacité de la de la vaccination si
on prend un modèle variole est assez est
stable et perdure longtemps dans au
cours du temps
et puis je pense qu'en ce qui me
concerne
je peux m'arrêter là il y avait les
données de tous les rangs sur la
vaccination là aussi on assure la
troisième génération un c'est pas le
vaccin qui a été donné dans les années
jusque dans les années 80 qui était un
vaccin de première génération qui était
relativement avec des quilles été
pourvus d'effets indésirables non
négligeable sur ce 3 sur ce vaccin de
troisième génération qui est aussi
réalisée à partir d'un vaccin vivant
mais non répliquent hâtif et donc on a
aussi un recul avec d'autres c'est une
stratégie vaccinale utilisée pour
d'autres agents infectieux et on a un
recul en termes de tolérance qui est
tout à fait favorable
qui continue de france et ensuite la
série mais dont je me permette de
répondre peut-être de manière groupée
puisque certaines questions sont
similaires donc j'ai bien noté une
question sur un éventuel emballement
c'est en fait très lié aux questions que
vous avez posent également sur des
modèles de prévision donc je répondrai à
ces deux questions ensemble également
sur les formes éventuellement
asymptomatique et enfin
sur les questions de comparaison par
rapport à d'autres pays européens
notamment l'angleterre on peut être sûr
les formes asymptomatiques d'abord
toutes ces questions je le précise
feront l'objet de discussions plusieurs
par semaine avec nos collègues des
autres agences européennes on a deux à
trois réunions hebdomadaires où
effectivement les pays font part de leur
expérience et donc sur la question des
cas asymptomatiques aujourd'hui la
question n'est pas résolue très peu
d'évidence
aucune publication revue par les pairs
nos collègues belges ont fait état d'
éventuellement trois cas alors
asymptomatiques ou possible
symptomatique c'est toute la difficulté
on peut avoir des formes cliniques très
frustrant éventuellement non reconnue
notamment si les éruptions sont sont peu
disséminés voir muqueuses et donc la
question n'est pas résolue et on ne sait
pas de toute façon même pour ceux ce
qu'elle reporte en belgique si les
personnes étaient contagieuses donc la
recherche poursuit et je pense que voilà
ça fait effectivement l'objet d'une
attention soutenue en lien avec nos
collègues cliniciens pour pouvoir les
documenter mais à ce jour il n'y a pas
d'évidence
solide sur le sujet
sur la question
de craintes d'un éventuel emballement en
fait nous dès le début de cette épidémie
on s'est mis en contact avec des équipes
de modélisation avec qui on travaille
depuis en fait de longues années et
notamment depuis la qu'ovide et donc on
partage nos données de surveillance avec
trois équipes de modélisation et on
avançait une réunion de travail ce matin
à laquelle je ne suis pas d'aimer des
collègues de mon équipe y sont pour
faire état de leurs premiers résultats
donc je ne peux pas vous en parler je ne
les connais pas ce que l'on connaît par
contre ce sont les travaux de nos
collègues anglais ils nous ont publié le
8 juillet école briefing où
effectivement leurs conclusions sont
très prudente puisque en gros ils ont
d'énormes incertitudes des intervalles
de confiance dans leurs prévisions qui
font qu'on ne sait pas si on va être sur
un plateau ou sur une augmentation donc
il ne conclut pas le cdc conduit
également des travaux de modélisation
mais là plus pour évaluer les stratégies
de prévention et notamment thaksin al
mais n'a pas
prévu de deux projections donc voilà
donc on devrait nous avoir des
projections nationales dans un proche
avenir en tout cas je l'espère mais
j'attendrai de prendre connaissance des
travaux des équipes de recherche avec
qui nous collaborons sur ce sujet
concerne enfin la question d'un éventuel
retard sur les anglais par ailleurs leur
épidémie a démarré avant la nôtre et on
est assez sûre du sujet je ne vais pas
dit tout à l'heure mais notre premier
cas date du 19 mai
on a vérifié par acquis de conscience
parce qu'on peut toujours éventuellement
raté des signaux on a regardé nos
données de surveillance syndromique je
pense que vous connaissez on a un
système de surveillance syndromique qui
nous permet de recueillir des données
syndromique de tous les services
d'urgence et des services hospitaliers
en en temps réel et on a donc interrogé
ces données de surveillance syndromique
de manière rétrospective sur les mois
précédents et nous n'avons pas identifié
de signal permettant de suspecter des
cas de manque et pax en france avant ce
premier cas du 19 mai on a par contre à
l'occasion effectivement de cette
interrogation de nos données de
surveillance syndromique identifié une
épidémie de varicelle mais bon voilà
voilà en tout cas on a fait cette
vérification est donc l'épidémie en
france est quand même assez décalé et
d'une intensité très inférieure à celle
observée en angleterre en allemagne ou
en espagne sur la question d'un éventuel
sous diagnostic là encore le plus
important c'est de sensibiliser les
patients et on a insisté tout à l'heure
effectivement sur le fait d'informer les
cliniciens
tellement lazarus a souligné
effectivement qu'il fallait pouvoir
faire connaître avec les initiants qui
ne connaissent pas cette maladie à quoi
elle ressemblait donc il ya un gros
travail fait par les cliniciens de
photothèque notamment pour diffuser ces
informations
et puis il faut sensibiliser les
patients aussi pour qu'ils consultent si
un patient ne consultent pas on ne peut
pas effectivement avoir connaissance de
ce cas voilà pour quelques éléments
chrétiens dr nassar couche
alors je vais essayer de répondre aux
questions sur les vaccins mais comme il
ya une question sur les surfaces d'abord
vous répond rapidement freitas t après
journée à la question des vaccins ce
qu'on a fait pour essayer de faciliter
le diagnostic et le dépistage vous avez
parfaitement raison ça c'est important
c'est une d'une part d'essayer d'élargir
au maximum les effecteurs et 2 les
laboratoires qui peuvent technique et
ces femmes en les prévenant qu'ils
peuvent se faire partout y compris en
ville et pour le prélèvement il ya un
acte qui est prévue à la nomenclature
des actes de biologie médicale et donc
ya pas de problème tous les laboratoires
de biologie médicale quand ils peuvent
faire lever le prélèvement et
éventuellement l'envoyer alors c'est des
circuits sont pas toujours simple mais
on y travaille en lien avec avec les
biologistes donc
réparti prélèvements s'annonce sur la
partie technique âge je vous ai dit il
ya une réglementation qui est lié au
fait que le monkey pox et un orthodoxe
virus que c'est potentiellement un agent
la réglementation mode donc donc il ya
des autorisations à avoir compris vos
pouvoirs technique et ensuite conserver
éventuellement ces échantillons avec la
nacelle on travaille sur les sur
l'allégement de cette réglementation
aujourd'hui qu'on a un virus qui circule
sur le territoire je peux pas préjuger
de de ski de ce qui arrive à mais c est
bien pris en compte tu es tu au niveau
de la biosécurité il s'agit à la fois
d'élargir les effecteurs et je vous ai
dit qu'on est passé d seul laboratoire
p3 des établissements de santé de
référence à l'ensemble des laboratoire
p3 hospitalier et bientôt si il ya la
vie à un avis de la chaise floral sur la
n1b m
olio p3 de ville ça permet de desserrer
et même que là où il n'y a pas de
laboratoires de niveau p 3 on pourrait
dégrader encore un peu les choses pour
qu'il ya un accès au diagnostic dans les
territoires qui est qui en auraient
besoin on fait aussi attention au fait
que quand on dégrade les
niveaux de biosécurité évidemment il
s'agit pas de mettre à risque les
travailleurs dans l'est dans les
laboratoires donc il ya un enjeu qui est
important là et il faut pas faire
n'importe quoi et puis la deuxième
champ d'action c'est sur les prod ce
jour d'être tout à l'heure c'est pas
encore pour tout de suite parce que il y
en a pas qui sont encore acceptée sur le
sur le marché on y travaille avec la nsm
selon deux axes trouver quelle qu'elles
sont les fournisseurs qui ont des tests
et qui ont des capacités
d'approvisionnement
et puis deuxièmement dès qu'on pourra en
avoir un petit peu travaillé notamment
avec les équipes de recherche et
notamment avec les wizz air il boit
beaucoup de patients à évaluer dans le
cadre d'un protocole de recherche les
performances de ces fraudes pour voir
s'ils ont une qualité satisfaisante
puisqu'il s'agit pas d'avoir plein de
faux négatifs ou plein de faux positifs
avec des marches pas si on a un
conditions réunies d'avoir une capacité
à avoir des approvisionnements et des
tests de bonnes performances et
effectivement on aura tout intérêt et je
crois que tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus à pouvoir déployer c'est rod et
notamment en ville dans l'est cegid
avoir répondu sur cette partie là je
reviens sur la partie vaccin sur la
question du décalage avec les autres
pays
bruno coignard a répondu à la fois sur
le décalage dans le temps et sur
l'intensité je voudrais simplement
préciser une chose sur les avis de la
chaise pour pas pour qu'on parle tous
bien de la même chose c'est que la vie
dure à mais qui a été rendue publique le
24 mai il ne traite que de la
vaccination post exposition que de la
vaccination des sujets contacts il ne il
ne traite pas de la vaccination
préventive ça c'est la vie qui a été
rendue la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas la même chose c'est pas
le même dimensionnement s'est pas
laissée pas les mêmes circuits et donc
c'est bien le dimensionnement suite à
thé cet avis
qui est qui et qui a lieu actuellement
sur les stocks
sur le secret défense
pour être précis ce qui est couvert par
secret défense je les dis c'est le
capacitaires et la composition du stock
c'est dans le cadre du plan variole et
c'est un plan qui est piloté par le
secrétariat général défense et de la
sécurité nationale et donc il m'a ne
m'appartient absolument pas de rentrer
dans ce détail là ce que je peux vous
dire et j'espère que ça répondra à une
partie de vos questions d'abord qu'on a
un stock suffisant de vaccins
à la fois contre la variole et pour
engager la vaccination
monkey pox
préventive après préventive et un espace
d'exposition vous avez raison madame la
présidente et ça me permet de répondre à
une autre de vos questions sur la
priorisation des indications la
priorisation qui est fait par la chasse
ce n'est pas une priorisation de gestion
des stocks ça pourrait l'être s'il y
avait besoin mais en l'occurrence c'est
vraiment une priorisation de medica de
souvenirs oui oui mais j'ai les mêmes
souvenirs je les partage avec vous
mais c'est bien une indication médicale
entre la gestion d'un risque immédiat
est avérée pour des personnes qui ont eu
un contact à risque documenté et évaluer
et qui sont susceptibles de développer
la maladie dans un terrain très courts
et une vaccination préventive pour une
population avec un risque potentiel qui
est un sur risque par rapport à l'an la
population générale donc on n'est pas
dans le même niveau de risques et donc
c'est logique d'avoir cette priorisation
dans les indications aussi
sur les stocks on a des niveaux de ceux
qui sont suffisants pour traiter ces
indications là et il ya des commandes
qui sont et qui sont pas complémentaires
qui ont été passé dès le début de cette
alerte et il ya une première livraison
qui est déjà intervenu et on a des
prochaines livraisons qui sont
programmés en août en septembre et à la
fin de l'année et on est en cours
d'instruction d'autres commandes
supplémentaires et je ne manque pas dans
le détail sur ce qui est livré
on a des stocks et des stocks
stratégiques plusieurs milliers de doses
qui sont déjà sur le terrain
notamment en ile de france puisque
l'évidence est là où le jeu se concentre
le gros de l'épidémie et
plusieurs milliers qui vont être
déstocker à brève échéance on est en
train de faire les plannings pour les
réapprovisionnements et les réassorts
dans les différents centres de
vaccination en fonction de leur
ouverture avec les ars et il ya déjà des
programmations qui sont en cours pour
les semaines à venir donc les doses sont
en train d'arriver sur le terrain il y
avait déjà les doses qui avaient été
prépositionnés pour la vaccination
post-exposition là on parle des
réapprovisionnements pré-exposition il
ya déjà des doses il y en aura qui sont
déjà prévues donc tout ça et est en
train de monter en charge
de manière assez forte sur les sur les
commandes j'ai répondu sur la
pharmacovigilance
effectivement c'est du domaine de la rsm
suisse a évidemment de manière
rapprochée et avec santé publique france
puisque ce sont des vaccins qui sont des
stockés depuis le stock stratégique de
santé publique france
et je crois que j'ai répondu à toutes
vos questions quand vous dites suffisant
vous avez évalué la cible
ça fait combien de personnes pas en gros
ah oui sur les délais vous avez
parfaitement pardon
sur les délais et effectivement ça nous
donne une souplesse logistique mais
c'est comme pour les autres vaccins à
dire que il ya une indication d'écart
entre les deux et puis on peut on peut y
aller la semaine suivant
sa réfection pour nous il souplesse
logistique au 6 mai mais c'est comme
pour les autres actions j'ai envie de
vous dire mon professeur lescure vous
pouvez préciser la cible
si je peux préciser ceci vous avez des
sources mais on a on avait on avait
les chercheurs en sciences sociales
avait ont des données assez précis sur
les prés peur en france sur les
personnes les hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec des hommes pratiquant le
les partenaires multiples et donc si
vous faites l'association des prêteurs
des vih positifs ou négatifs ayant ce
type de conduite à risque vous arrivez
sur un total d'environ 120 mille
personnes
avant qu'on passe aux autres questions
est ce que le fait de cibler uniquement
les personnes que vous venez définir
est-ce qu'on va passer à côté de cas
chez d'autres personnes c'est ma
question est est ce que est ce que en
plus c'est un côté très stigmatisante
donc comment vous vous traiter ça en
terme de communication
alors si la présence sur votre question
va-t-on passer à côté d'autres profils
c'est l'objet effectivement est notre
priorité actuellement dans les démarches
de surveillance on a bien caractérisés
aujourd'hui la principale populations à
risque hommes ayant des rapports sexuels
avec les hommes notamment
multipartenaires mais nous restons
vigilants pour justement détecter
d'éventuelles modifications avec des cas
qui seraient rapportés de manière plus
fréquente chez des femmes chez des
enfants bien évidemment ou chez des
travailleurs du sexe par exemple
aujourd'hui les données dont j'ai fait
état voilà ce sont les dernières données
de nous disposons mais nous concentrons
bien évidemment nos investigations sur
ces formes qui serait atypique
alors laurence cohen et guillotin
mélanie laurent oui merci madame la
présidente merci messieurs pour ces
ces éléments en fait non mais question
vents vont poursuivre ce qui vous a déjà
été posée parce que effectivement le
discours on va dire officiel un de la
dgs paraît voilà on maîtrise tout on
tient tout on a tout anticiper donc a
pris en compte visiblement la pandémie
du coronavirus mais ça c'est sur le
papier mais en même temps on n'a aucun
chiffre
on est obligé de vous croire sur parole
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué vous
l'avouerez pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes alors moi je d'abord une
première chose je ne comprends pas votre
argument de secret défense je ne vois
pas ce que le la secren la défense des
affaires dans l'histoire il ne me semble
pas peut-être que je me suis ça m'a
échappé il me semble il ne semble pas
que le secret défense était invoquée
pour pour la pandémie pour un un virus
mais je voilà donc pourquoi tout d'un
coup ils seraient invoquée ici c'est ma
première première question deuxième
question
docteur lazarus j'ai pas très bien
compris parce que vous avez dit en
parlant donc de cette variole du singe
que ce n'était pas une infection
sexuellement transmissible
mais que ça s'en approchait et laowai et
soit sexuellement transmissibles et s'en
approcher là non plus je vois pas donc
est-ce que je peux avoir quelques
petites précisions là dessus ensuite
vous avez dit que les centres de
vaccination vous aviez donné des des
consignes pour qu'ils soient ouverts
quand les plus qu'ils soient ouverts 70
centres de vaccination si j'ai bien
combien écouter
mais est-ce que c'est 70 centres de
vaccination vont avoir les nombre de
doses à la fois en préventif et en
curatif qu'est-ce que voilà est ce que
on peut avoir plus de précision là
dessus
et puis
je voudrais savoir aussi au niveau de
l'anticipation c'est à dire par rapport
aux commandes et par rapport à la
production parce qu'on a bien vu là
pendant le grand navire us que moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que on était
plus que faible pour pas dire inexistant
en termes de production des vaccins là
je voudrais savoir si la france est en
capacité de produire ces vaccins et puis
peut-être savoir également ses vaccins
ils viennent de quel labo séquelles la
bo kyi qui fournit qui fournit les
vaccins on est dépendant de quoi pour
savoir à quelle sauce on peut être mangé
c'est à yzeure ou d'autres voilà merci
davance alors vernet guillotin et pour
terminer mais l'année prochaine alors
merci madame la présidente je décide
d'aller vite dans mes questions j'en
avais plein mais elles ont quasiment
toutes étaient à l'ordre du jour donc je
vais les oublier la prévention
épidémiologue des l'évaluation des
vaccins c'est les 3 premières je voulais
poser je les évacue il en reste deux
est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui par
définition sur une endémie une épidémie
ou est-ce qu'on surveille uniquement des
cas sporadiques enfin jeu voilà à peu
près quel sac et a donné sa première
question et la deuxième c'est sûr je
n'ai pas très bien compris sur la
transmission 1 est-ce qu'on est sur une
maladie visiblement qui était tranquille
et transmise au départ par le rongeur à
l'homme donc est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
soit mordu fin je sais pas et ça
impliquerait des préventions sur les
métiers exposés aux rongeurs et la
deuxième transmission interhumaine est
ce que c'est une transmission de contact
pur ou est ce que c'est une transmission
avec une composante d'un des infections
sexuellement transmissibles par
sécrétion par sécrétions génitales et du
coup est ce qu a une prévention sur
spécifique parce qu'on n'a pas parlé de
rapports sexuels protégés des choses
comme ça sur les publics dont on dit
qu'ils sont plus spécifiquement atteint
possible l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup merci pour cet exposé je
suis désolé de revenir avec la même
question qui va un peu vous embêter mais
j'avoue que moi aussi j'ai du mal à
comprendre l'utilisation d'arguments du
secret défense parce qu en fait on vous
pose pas la question de savoir combien
il ya de vaccins en stock
nous protéger d'une éventuelle attaque
biologique dans le cadre qui mettrait en
péril la sécurité nationale j'espère
d'ailleurs fait je ne sais pas mais
enfin que ces stocks las de toute façon
seront préservés et que ce qu'on utilise
pour vacciner la population générale qui
est
potentiellement
sujette à aux infections ne réduit pas
notre capacité à nous défendre contre
une guerre biologique donc c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué pour nous je ne
comprends pas ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi le secret défense
s'appliquerait à des stocks de vaccins
qui ne sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
vocation à être utilisé dans le cadre
d'une attaque sur notre sécurité
nationale
ensuite si vous voulez quand même pas
nous répondre sur combien on a deux
vaccins jeu s'est posé la question
différemment est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire combien de doses sont prévues
pour être des stockés dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent on a une petite
indication dit 120000 donc ça c'est
si j'ai bien compris les hommes voient
la cible hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec les hommes et sont prêtes
je crois que ça compte ça exclut les
travailleurs du sexe etc j'imagine c'est
donc un petit peu au dessus de ça le
public cible
parce que la question suivante c'est
les remontées de terrain qu'on a en fait
on vous poserai pas cette question sur
les stocks s'ils en gros elle est
remontée de terrain qu'on avait c'était
ben en fait tout va bien les gens qui
ont besoin de se faire vacciner arrive à
avoir un rendez vous pour ce faire
vacciner on se pose la question parce
que les remontées qu'on a c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de rendez-vous disponibles
docteur docteur lille a été activée je
prends la frontière bon ben en une demi
journée il n'y avait pas ya plus de
rendez-vous disponible via des régions
ont disent qu'il n'ya pas du tout de
cendres qui apparaissent et donc la
question c'est pas du coup c'est quoi le
problème si c'est pas une question de
stock qu'est ce qui explique en fait que
les rendez-vous sont pas disponibles et
à quel terme on peut résoudre le
problème est la raison pour laquelle on
est à l'inquiétude sur les stocks et
qu'on comprend pas trop c'est que là je
me trompe peut-être mais l'union
européenne à une semble organisé un
achat groupé de vaccins
la france à
décidé de ne pas faire partie de cet
achat groupé
pourquoi et quelle est la raison est
est ce que ça a un rapport avec le fait
qu'on est en difficulté aujourd'hui pour
assurer les vaccinations
l'autre question c'est est sûre est ce
que vous pourriez médicalement nous dire
les personnes qui ont été vaccinées pour
la variole avant qu'on arrête donc en
1984 le
ce que vous estimez être leur niveau de
protection par rapport à la période du
singe
ensuite j'ai une question sur les yeux
sur les protocoles de d'isolement donc
les personnes qui ont été infectées qui
sont pas hospitalisés qui sont donc si
j'ai bien compris en isolement on a
quand même des retours des personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément qu'ils sont pas
suivies
comme il faudrait ou qu'ils aient pas
qu'ils n'ont pas assez d'informations
sur ce qu'elles doivent faire pendant la
période d'isolement comment vous gérez
le contact avec les patients qui sont en
isolement mais non hospitalisés et la
dernière question donc plutôt pour le
gouvernement c'est effectivement en 1 on
a une maladie qui n'est pas et c'est
bien le rappeler à proprement parler
sexuellement transmissibles dans sa
lettre pas transmissible par aidés par
le sperme etc mais elle touche pour tout
un tas de raisons aujourd'hui une
communauté en particulier
moi je suis un peu inquiète des
différents
violences discriminations qui peuvent
être générées par ça on a vu au début de
l'épidémie ducobu qui avait des
personnes
identifiées comme chinoise qui se
faisait agresser dans le métro dans la
rue est ce que au delà de la de la
communication en termes de prévention
médicale vous pensez aussi à une
communication
sur ce sujet là pour éviter qu'on ait
des violences et des attaques envers les
communautés cibles merci merci alors
qu'ils commencent
monsieur poignard vous demander tassé à
ses concerts je peux répondre sur la
question
sur s unit est effectivement eu
cette question d'être important car il
ya plusieurs définitions de liesse était
une infection sexuellement transmissible
stricto sensu c'est une inflexion qui
est lié à un agent pathogène qui a été
retrouvé dans les sécrétions génitales
aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet
effectivement bien évidemment de travaux
il ya quelques publications qui font
état de présence d' adn viral dans le
sperme mais est ce que il s'agit d'un
virus infectieux ça reste à prouver donc
aujourd'hui on a pas d'évidence pour
appliquer cette définition donc au sens
strict aux sangsues aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas dire que c'est une ist après il
ya une définition plus large de l' oms
de lui et astier qui est celle de toute
infection qui se transmet lors de
rapports sexuels non protégés
la notion de rapport non protégé doit
ici être comprise comme non protégé par
un préservatif externe ou interne donc
là aussi c'est cesser il faut faire
attention parce que si on qualifie le
monkey pox d'y rester on va laisser
penser éventuellement à certaines
parties de la population que porter un
préservatif entre tech qui n'est pas le
cas puisqu'on l'a rappelé c'est une
infection qui se transmet principalement
par des contacts directs de poids à pau
en contact avec un patient qu'il ya des
lésions
voilà donc c'est pas non plus une
nouveau je rappelle qu'on a eu il ya
quelques années des épidémies d'e comme
l'herpès on a eu il ya quelques années
aussi d épidémie d'hépatite à ou de
shiga lowe's dans des communautés
homosexuelles masculines et c'était des
modes de transmission aussi de
pathogènes non étiquetés y rester mais
qui survenait dans le cadre de rapports
sexuels donc aujourd'hui
ni le cd sénile oms ne considère ni les
cdc aux états unis ne considèrent
l'infection a manqué pas comme une ist
mais par contre on est tous d'accord sur
le fait qu'elle peut se transmettre
durant des contacts intimes entre
personnes et c'est vrai qu'à ce titre ce
n'est pas et clément lazarus ça l'a
rappelé une maladie
qui se limite qui est spécifique de la
communauté homosexuelle masculine
aujourd'hui c'est la principale
populations à risque mais comme je le
dis on reste très vigilant sur la
détection de cas qui se transmettrait
dans les mêmes circonstances mais dans
d'autres populations donc pour répondre
aussi à la question est ce qu'on est sur
une endémie une épidémie on est
clairement aujourd'hui sur une épidémie
qui se concentrent principalement dans
une communauté
homosexuelle masculine avec de rares
cajoler rappelé 5k féminin et de cas
pédiatriques qui sortent un peu de ce
profil
je crois que j'ai répondu aux questions
que j'avais repéré mais je suis prêt à
compléter si besoin monsieur lazarus sur
le secret défense dites nous tout alors
je vais vous dire sur le secret défense
donc sur le secret défense
je voulais dit ce stock de vaccin
antivariolique
il a été constituée dans le cadre du
plan variole jeu le plan variole il est
piloté par le secrétariat général de la
défense et la sécurité nationale est
donc le secret lui appartient le secret
lui à partir si je vous divulgue les
choses qui sont couverts par le secret
je risque cinq ans de prison et 100
mille euros damende je vous trouve très
pousse au crime mais voilà j'essaie de
tenir bon
les vaccins qui sont dans ce stock je
rende pas dans le détail pour les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer mais
ayant cédé son dd vaccin contre la
variole et qu'on peut utiliser pour le
vaccin de troisième génération pour le
mans qui boxe et donc c'est ça qu'on est
en train de faire c'est qu'on les
utilise dans une autre indication que
celle du stock à ce stade le stock est
toujours que couverts par le secret et
et ça perdure on verra si nous on n'a
pas d'intérêt particulier à ce que ça
fait c'est le choix je le dis clairement
ce qui ce qui est important c'est ce
qu'on livre sur le terrain et ce qu'on
prévoit d'approvisionner ce que je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui je vous ai dit
quelques milliers de doses qui sont déjà
assurés sur le terrain et d'autre
quelques milliers qui sont en cours je
peux préciser un peu les choses
on a déjà des stocks et 7500 dose et on
a cinq mille doses qui sont déjà prévues
pour la semaine prochaine et cela dès la
semaine suivante et on continuera comme
ça en fonction des besoins des ars qui
est qui nous sont remontés et on
organise le schéma logistique avec santé
publique france et avec au fur et à
mesure des ouvertures de centres de
vaccination c'est pas le seul facteur
qui pourra être limitant je pense pas
d'ailleurs que ça le choix puisque on
lire en fonction des besoins
ça peut prendre un peu de temps vous
monsieur
vous me ferez grâce je répondre à votre
question mais vont sur les gascons et
aussi la semaine du 14 juillet est donc
que même avec la meilleure volonté des
services de l'état et avec ces
opérateurs s'est pas complètement
tribales comme contrainte et donc on
continue à y travailler et puis il ya
aussi toutes les contraintes de terrain
d'ailleurs qu'il faut avoir les bras
pour vacciner les organisations et ça
nécessite du monde des ressources
humaines et davier qui connaît bien ces
contrats pour vous en parler c'est aussi
ça la vraie vie et la réalité du terrain
on essaye de fait de monter en charge
tous collectivement pour pouvoir offrir
avoir une offre de vaccination qui soit
satisfaisante qui permette que les gens
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner le soit
on continue à les halles faire et on va
suivre les choses et c'est bien
l'objectif
sur les commandes je voulais dit il ya
eu il y avait déjà des stocks qui était
présent dès le début de l' alerte on a
refait des commandes il y à une
livraison qui est arrivé il ya d'autres
livraisons qui seront programmés et il
ya des commandes qui sont à l'étude donc
on continue c'est bien sûr la question
du de la commande européenne merci
danser dans une cadre de cette commande
la priorité est donnée à des pays qui
n'ont pas de stocks nous on a un stock
et donc l'idée est plutôt d'être
solidaires avec nos collègues européens
et que ceux qui le souhaitent puissent
commander des stocks et donc c'est comme
ça que quand on agit on insulte pas
l'avenir de dire que dans le futur on
essaye d'être aghmat ticket d'agir dans
un cadre européen
coordonné
sur les antécédents d'accession variole
bayahi garn avis de la haute autorité de
santé effectivement ils ont besoin que
d'une seule dose qui indique bien que il
ya un niveau de protection qui qui
préexiste évidemment plus l'ancienneté
du vaccin est importante - le niveau de
protection et ford
précisé et sur l'isolément oui sur les
personnes qui ont vraiment besoin d'un
accompagnant l isolement il peut arriver
qu'ils aient des hospitalisations pour
accompagnement à l isolement qui soit
faite l'espère pourra vous en parler les
ars quand elles le peuvent les grands
textes renaissance d'un cas qui a mal
mais du mal à s'isoler peuvent les
accompagner appelé plusieurs fois dans
la semaine et ses devoirs et avoir une
action pragmatique
et il faut qu'on continue l isolement a
fortiori sur une période aussi longue de
21 jours c'est pas c'est pas simple et
on le prend en compte aussi
etc il faut qu'on continue à y
travailler ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous
et
le labo en fait je suis en train de
poser la question et le labo s'appelle
bavaria nordiques
et je suis en train de poser la question
de savoir me répond c'est un labo danois
avec des filiales en allemagne en suisse
et aux etats unis
mais j'avoue que je séchais sur la
question donc j'ai fait un appel à mes
collègues
ah oui ce sont des multidoses le
sermonner à doses unitaires
alors il ya des conditions de de
température pour la conservation et le
transport qui fait que ce sujet et a
complètement simple parce que c'est du
moins 80 en stockage et moins et moins
20 en transport on peut pas s'abstraire
des dr cp du fabricant on regarde de
manière très rapprochée avec son débit
france avec la nacelle toutes les
marches de facilitation qu'on peut se
donner mais c'est pourtant simple on a
aussi l'expérience du duc au vide sur le
moins 80 qui et qui nous aide un petit
peu
alors qu'il continue vous souhaitez
prolonger un petit peu et puis ensuite
en fait y aller ce que pour terminer oui
moi je voulais donner quelques éléments
sur la question de la discrimination de
la population lgbt ça c'est quelque
chose auquel on a été extrêmement
sensible dès le début et on est en
travail très en lien le dr lazarus l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure avec les des
associations lgbt on travaille avec eux
depuis longtemps on travaille sur le
terrain avec eux c'est eux qui diffuse
nos nos flyers et et je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure il considère aussi que c'est que
ce chef est une référence et donc le
choix qu'on l'a fait en matière de
communication c'est de cibler cette
population là mais on vraiment en termes
de cible comme en marketing et en
revanche djamel évoqué pour essayer de
limiter au maximum les amalgames et plus
largement sur la question de la
discrimination on est dans une démarche
à santé publique france 2 d'essayer de
faire évoluer dans le bon sens les
représentations de l'ensemble de la
population sur ces questions en
particulier sur les populations lgbt et
bien et pour terminer professeur lescure
pour compléter des points des réponses
courtes de la première sur les centres
de vaccination
aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé clément
lazarus il ya des centres qui sont
référencés mais c'est vrai que pour tout
vous dire certains ne sont pas encore
activé et comme le disait clément on est
dans une période compliquée pour
actionner des activités nouvelles et je
pense que malgré tout tout le monde fait
preuve de bonne volonté dans le contexte
mais c'est vrai que premièrement il ya
du monde qui du monde au portillon entre
guillemets et donc on a des beaucoup de
déceptions en termes de des attentes et
on a des rendez vous qui sont beaucoup
trop loin par rapport à des
a1 était que les gens aimeraient plus
festif et moins contraints pour résumer
les affaires et deuxièmement on a
beaucoup de difficultés sur le terrain à
prioriser le post exposition par rapport
à la pré exposition notamment par
exemple sur des prises de rendez-vous
d'octo libre etc et donc il ya des
difficultés opérationnelles qui qui qui
sont toujours présentes deuxième point
sur la question des ist je reviendrai
pas sur la définition très précise du
docteur
bruno coignard pardon ce qui est clair
c'est que et comme le disait clément
lazarus
aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes les
preuves mais on a un certain nombre
d'éléments dans un faisceau qui
probablement concours à
considérer de façon pragmatique eux on
peut qu'on peut parler d'y rester de
façon pragmatique
les anglais recommande le port du
préservatif jusqu'à huit semaines après
le virus a été détecté dans les liquides
biologiques notamment liquide séminal et
le sperme
pour les virologues on a un virus
extrêmement solide et donc quand on
trouve ce virus on considère et les
virologues considère qu'il est infecté
et on a une sémiologie au niveau génital
et au niveau des muqueuses qui semble
évoquer
vraiment une transmission par le rapport
sexuel au delà des contacts répétés
intime haut niveau au niveau cutané
le troisième point par rapport à la
question des laboratoires ça a été ça a
été précisé il ya deux laboratoires
un effectivement danois et l'autre
américain sur la question
de la population cible ces 120 milles
dont quarante mille très peur
sur la question du niveau de protection
[Musique]
on a des études qui sont pas publiés
qu'ils viennent de du laboratoire des
virus émergents de marseille qui dans
une étude de séroprévalence en france
montre le niveau de protection en termes
d'anticorps efficace contre la variole
et donc protecteur quand remontent les
pokes aux alentours de 10% qui est à peu
près la proportion de personnes de plus
de 50 ans
qui ont une vaccination c'est que la
vaccination a s'est arrêté avant et que
le les bacs l'arrêt de la vaccination a
été anticipé sur les recommandations
et donc on a une population cible non
immunes très importante en france
vous parliez des difficultés à l'
isolement on le voit sur le terrain
et faisons ça a été rappelé les
difficultés aussi du contact racim du
contact racing font que là vaccination
pré exposition est clairement bienvenu
que si l'on inscrive de contenir la
dynamique de de ce virus et dernier
point par rapport au dr clément lazerus
qui parlait de cadre européen coordonné
pour donner une bonne nouvelle aussi en
termes de recherche sur la maladie les
choses et on a beaucoup tiré de leçons
par rapport à ce qui a été fait sur kobe
au début il y à une cohorte européenne
et une seule qui permettra de se décrire
l'histoire naturelle de la maladie dans
les contrées en dehors de la zone
d'endémie et il y à des discussions pour
avoir des essais cliniques
multicentriques
multi pays qui sont en cours aujourd'hui
au plus haut niveau des organisations
non gouvernementales
ok merci beaucoup pour ces précisions on
va suivre l'évolution de 7000 est
important est fait pour notre commission
qu'on puisse vous entendre donc merci à
tous les quatre ans de participation ce
matin et bonne fin d'après midi je
rappelle à mes collègues que nous avons
rendez vous salle rené coty